it's an unusual name
how is she how did you spell it in E aah
bb8 HH where you from version originally
Boston Massachusetts and you grew up
with both parents one day I grew up with
my mom and my stepfather how was your
childhood it was is crazy um my father
was drug dealer engineer drug dealer
engineer by day drug dealer at night you
know what crazy things drawing up things
I probably should have seen from uncles
just physical abuse
Vince abuse my mother you know my father
was all my stepfather was ill never
abused me kind of protected me so I
loved him very much
it's always
and the sexual abuse was of what age did
sir about four or five there's a lot of
it or just uh yeah a lot of it any time
they would get a chance you know my
mother wasn't a very vigilant person she
believed that if you were like insane
culture you wouldn't hurt someone like
like she just had real ignorant beliefs
and thoughts you know and I never
believed a word I said
and so
what is really left out I didn't tell my
mother threw me out I was 13 3 article
13 and we mention five days before
business five days before Christmas
where did you go from there
I would see people live with a pimp in
his prostitutes and I started selling
crack for them you were to give her a
heavy sex for money no I was always
really afraid of men because of what
happened to me when I was younger but
then I did end up meeting someone that
ended up abusing me even more and making
me more more unstable than it was you
know gentlemen you know now I look back
on it and I'm like you know predator he
was a predator back you know but um and
that made my life even more my mental
state spin out of control I did continue
going to school and educate myself you
know right now I was never able to
really hold down I have gotten great
jobs I've never been able to hold city
job down because of my mind you know
just racing thoughts all the time things
have happened to me you know so
I think it was 27 when we started using
out who's 27
that was the first time your show just
shot pain everything we just just went
away
you know it wasn't the most pleasant
experience you know because I threw up
and was just gross but the thought of me
not thinking about things that have
happened to me the thought of not
jumping when there's a certain noise as
I have I was diagnosed with severe PTSD
and bipolar schizoaffective and that was
all after the use you know so yeah and I
used 427 till I was 35 I believe and
then I stopped
my husband lost everything I lost my
children I lost
you know I lost all sense of stability I
lost when we got together never not why
is that because I didn't know he was a
raging drug addict and then that just
triggered my addiction is also started
using again and he was severely abusive
physically abusive for many years we
were together for seven years and for
seven years I was beat for mourning too
late he took me away from my children
took away from my family
winds out of here in California within
six months of being here he got four
prostitute pregnant he himself started
prostituting himself to men and now he's
involved in this sex trafficking thing
that they do down here in Skid Row and
I've been held hostage and tense because
of him I've been raped that sex ring
place told him that to warn me there so
he lured me there and they had him
watched and while they raped and beat me
my husband he robbed me for a mine
like my my pension like he's done a
horrible things me has had me beat up so
that I wouldn't go down the street where
where they're at so I want to witness or
hear anything but I have it's just the
worst thing in the world just doing
something like that so that even spun
like my addiction worse outta control
worse you know dealing with that just
these people you know hearing him
getting great you know and a part of me
is like good that's karma you know who
would use its keep it in the day that's
a human being you know you don't deserve
that none of us deserve what's happening
down here yeah you don't trust you know
one cup to drink
no because you don't know what they're
gonna do
there's parasites down here people are
dying from parasites like alarms and
stuff coming out of it bodies that be
extremely cautious down here um I used
to tell my husband this is like the
first level of hell you know because
it's so you know it's horrible you know
like if you sit down by the end of
Concord at night all you hear is
screaming from all these people that are
being held Austin intensive nobody does
anything can you do if you say anything
enjoy you're gonna be next so I'm just
you know today I'm just get myself
together and you know go to treatment
and you know honey get out of here you
know I came to California when to
publish my books that write and
screenplays and I read books poetry and
we came here with a plan so I'm just
gonna have to carry it out you know
because I came here with a purpose and
I'm gonna I'm gonna do it you know
whatever
I came here to do you know I know my
daughter
um beautiful woman she's gorgeous
I don't know what I know they're Mauston
but I don't have her number I don't have
contact with my sons
I have a little girl her name's ivory
she was in Texas trying to get her but
she's also involved you know a lot of
stuff and I really want to be with my
children doing my baby I can't
I've left messages on Facebook you know
I tell you this is the man took me away
from everyone he took me away from
everything
but it's just up to me now I think it's
strong more you just just keep looking
forward and don't look back get back
I have dreams and goals my best little
life for anyone you know I weigh 80
pounds 8 pounds sick very sick now you
know and I haven't even gone to the
hospital and you know because I think
the the drug is so powerful you know
that one has plans but one doesn't carry
them out you know because this is just
it takes over it takes the essence of
who you are very essence of your
spirituality who you are it's gone
you're just an empty shell I've been
naughty for a year now this time around
yeah yeah just here and within that year
everything
and the only thing I still have is you
know education you know and and at least
I still have some sense of sensibility
yes definitely